[Music]
Pippi Tino Italy's northernmost town
lies at the foot of the Alps and South
Tyrol the perfect place to enjoy la
dolce vita the family-run hotel lamb is
in the heart of town this is where head
chef Anton visa creates traditional
Italian and regional dishes like Trista
Canada literally say or Tyrolean trio he
made a film with us how dumplings used
to be the farmers main meal today
they're a speciality at elite date you
need stale white bread for the dumplings
Stephanie baka the hotel mums
housekeeper fix some up every day from
the local Baker let the guys at the
bakery it's cut into small chunks
this is day-old white bread the basis
for our traditional dumplings the
Tyrolean trio is ravioli and two kinds
of dumplings one is a cheese dumpling to
make it Anton visa needs day-old bread
milk cheese eggs chives and green onions
first he sautés the green onions in
butter okay Ben add some milk the milk
is only warmed slightly and then poured
over the chunks of day-old bread
whoop allow all on it soaks up lukewarm
milk add the cheese chives eggs and then
season to taste and lastly some flour to
bind the dough together
mix well no optimality I guess we it's
tough to say how to make the optimal
dough because it depends how hard the
bread is the dough simply has to stick
together clean
this is what the ideal dough looks like
this well it is to the eyelid II then
let the dough sit for 30 minutes to
absorb the flavors now for the spinach
dumplings will need blanch the spinach
onions fever garlic butter eggs nutmeg
what milk and flour me want mainly look
and of course lots of cubes of day-old
bread the spinach dumplings are made the
same way as the cheese ones and the
dough is also left to rest afterwards
it's time to shape the dumplings
Anton makes the cheese ones into long
ovals and bowls the spinach ones into
balls
ijuin are common could also form the
spinach dough into ovals the shapes the
only difference the dough's always the
same let the dumplings simmer in salted
water for 15 minutes no it's time to
make the [ __ ] up or ravioli should look
like a you can guide hair Kreutzer with
Swabian or italian ravioli the
difference is just that here you use rye
flour because rye was the flour that the
farmers January was the power couple
iced tea cut out the shapes the pasta
dough is filled with blanched spinach
and ricotta cheese then the ravioli is
also placed gently into simmering water
if looks of the ravioli need to cook for
3 to 5 minutes just enough time to dish
out the spinach and cheese dumplings
then the ravioli season the Tyrolean
trio with grated Parmesan cheese and
brown butter this dish may be high in
calories but it's also big on
Makana thumb oven you created in summer
as well as winter this dumplings filled
with tangy cheese the spinach dumpling
has the vegetable meaning you mean
there's the delicate ravioli all
seasoned with butter and Parmesan an
all-around great taste the Tyrolean trio
has been on the menu at Hotel LOM for
more than three decades it's a dish
that's loved by locals and tourists
alike a taste of South Tirol to remember
you
[Music]